representative Marjorie Taylor green
revealed that her husband has filed for
divorce after 27 years of marriage he
officially blamed irreconcilable
differences for the split while she
blamed the Jews
and now a correction to a story we ran
last week Prince Charles is actually the
one in the middle
we apologize for that Muslim student at
a high school in California was upset
after the school yearbook falsely
printed her name as Isis while the
yearbook also mistakenly identified
their only Asian student as Kung Fu
Panda
fishing price has launched an online
Museum showcasing its toys over the past
90 years or you can see them in person
at America's most famous Toy Museum the
Neverland Ranch
[Music]
[Applause]
Hefty has introduced pumpkin spice into
trash bags and I gotta say pumpkin spice
into trash bags is probably the best
slur for white people I've ever heard
in a new Scooby-Doo Halloween special
the character Velma is openly depicted
as a lesbian
finally
she was openly depicted as a lesbian
which explains why Scooby is now a
rescue pit bull
[Music]
[Laughter]
last night the Epic disaster film
twister opened to big box office and
some controversy the Reverend Jesse
Jackson has called for a boycott of the
movie claiming that not enough black
people in the film are killed by
tornadoes
all right
a British version of RuPaul's Drag Race
will begin airing next year on the BBC
and because it's England their penises
will be tucked to the right side
[Laughter]
some doctors are worried about a new
recommendation asking them to encourage
middle-aged women to lose weight also
worried about women losing too much
weight black guys
[Laughter]
Sesame Street has introduced two new
black Muppets to help explain racial
difference to Children which begs the
question are these Muppets White
Kelsey Grammer announced that he will
star in a Revival of Frasier for those
of you too young to remember Frazier was
the show that made friends look black
the group advocating replacing Andrew
Jackson on the 20 bill with a woman
announced that the winner of the poll
for the new face of the currency is
Harriet Tubman it's a move that could
have racist all over saying can I get
that intense
130 years after the Civil War the state
of Mississippi has finally voted to
abolish slavery Representatives say they
would have liked to have done it sooner
but they were delayed due to some
awfully big cotton crops they had to had
some I'm gonna have a big cotton thing
all right
Warner Warner Brothers is producing a
new movie in which Superman is black and
a black Superman actually makes a lot of
sense when you remember that Superman
was abandoned by his parents as a victim
foreign
has become the first state in the South
to abolish the death penalty so if
you'll excuse me I've got some white
women to whistle at
last week on Larry King live Marlon
Brando made the shocking statement that
Hollywood is quote run by Jews
in response outrage Jewish organizations
made it snow in New York in April
foreign
[Applause]
about this one now an auction of Nazi
memorabilia was held which featured
items such as Hitler's top hat and Ava
bronze dress and it's tough to auction
off Nazi memorabilia because everyone
always looks like they're bidding
Applause I liked it police in Ohio say
that a report of a homeless man sleeping
on a bench turned out to be a statue
which was a huge relief because they
shot it 15 times
this week is taxi cab appreciation week
so to all you taxi cab drivers out there
I'd appreciate it if you'd take a shower
once in a while
[Music]
a Michigan man is planning to run over 3
000 miles in a hundred days as an homage
to Forrest Gump and a straight up Fu to
Lieutenant Dan
almost a hundred art industry figures
have criticized four different Museum
plans to postpone exhibits featuring an
artist's paintings of the KKK but if you
want to see portraits of clansmen you
can always search Jost on ancestry.com
[Applause]
okay well whatever
an obese monkey in Thailand named
Godzilla has been sent to a special
facility to lose weight officials
realize the monkey was overweight when a
bunch of black guys kept hitting on it
that's pretty racist God police are
being the best investigated after video
surfaced of them using excessive force
on a homeless black man accused of
urinating in public but I say great
great work keeping our streets clean
boys
yes sir anything the police do is all
right with old Mikey Chase
this week marks the 65th anniversary of
Rosa Parks refusing to give up her seat
on an Alabama bus and I just wish that
all black people could follow her
example of sitting down and shutting up
[Applause]
the White House has introduced a new
plan to put nutrition labels on the
front instead of the back so to give you
an idea of the overall health of
Americans we're too lazy to do this
it's a lot
it's alive
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
I've been trying for several years the
New York City commission voted to remove
a statue of Thomas Jefferson from City
Hall they were finally able to remove it
by telling the statue there was a hot
black lady outside
[Laughter]
officials at the Barcelona Zoo revealed
that four lions at the facility tested
positive for Coronavirus even more
shocking it's because they attended a
Hasidic wedding
it was revealed that the sequel to the
movie Hocus Pocus is in the works for
Disney plus which by judging what's
judging by this picture is a movie about
every white woman I've ever slept with
foreign
PLO leader Yasser Arafat announced this
week that his wife is pregnant a happy
couple said they really don't care if
the child is a boy or a girl just as
long as it hates Jews
tomorrow is Easter Sunday so to all you
Christians out there happy Easter and to
the Jews nice try
a man proposed a man proposed to his
longtime girlfriend while she was in the
middle of the New York City marathon
because what woman can resist a man who
doesn't wait for her to finish
well I knew you'd like that one so
here's another one
Warner Brothers is producing a new movie
in which Superman is black in this
version black Superman's kryptonite is
an honest day's work
[Applause]
whoa in the wake of the verdict angry
Menendez defense attorney Leslie
Abramson said the jury simply chose not
to believe the brother's excuse that
they had been sexually abused by their
father and says she knows why quote it's
because my clients are black
[Laughter]
second has posted her first ever picture
on Instagram finally a chance for
commoners to directly tell the queen
show feet
foreign
[Applause]
Wisconsin men have been charged with
felony hate crimes after burning a man's
buggy simply because he was Amish if
convicted the men face up to 25 years in
prison but Furious Amish leaders say
that is not enough they want the dunking
wheel
created the whitest paint on record the
paint is so white eye in its favorite
part of SNL